[Music]
five years ago
almost to the day i was sitting on the
floor of a bathroom stall
in ronald reagan airport crying
even pre-covet it's not a spot i'd
recommend
it was a busy monday morning and i was
getting ready to fly out for another
long week of management consulting
after eight months on the job i was used
to feeling stressed
but that morning when i sat down at my
gate
i started to panic my mind went blank my
hands were numb
my heart was racing and i was sweating
with
dread at the thought of another week of
wall-to-wall work
when i talked to my hr person later that
day she told me it sounded like i'd had
an anxiety attack
you can think of that like the
precocious younger sibling of a panic
attack
she comforted me and she said don't
worry this happens
all the time and she was right
it does happen all the time when i tell
my burnout story at the gsb
people often say me too i had a
breakdown at the airport
or they tell me about missing a friend's
wedding or grandparent's funeral to work
on a deal
or how they never had time for therapy
or how they had a relationship or
friendship
unravel during a busy time at work
today i'm going to talk to you about
overwork and burnout in u.s professional
culture
and how we can start to change it
u.s professionals work more than we did
30 years ago
and more than our counterparts and other
wealthy nations
that overwork is linked to increased
rates of stress
heart disease anxiety and depression
a lot of people women in particular quit
their high-powered jobs
because they can't afford to sacrifice
their health or family well-being
even for a job they love
stories like mine happen all the time
you might expect me to talk about
policies that can make this better
what mental health care child care
flexible work arrangements can make
these intense jobs
more bearable and that's an important
question
but i want to get to the root of the
problem and ask why we are all
so convinced that high impact rewarding
work
needs to entail a 60-plus hour week
because i don't think it should
a lot of people assume that working long
hours makes you more productive
i'll use this scientific chart to show
how people think about productivity
a climb to the top fueled by hustle and
stamina
until you reach the pinnacle of
productivity where everything you touch
turns to gold yeah maybe it gets bad if
you overstep things but that probably
won't happen to you
right research on
sleep brain functioning and actual
people at work
all tell a different story i'll use this
chart to show what actually happens
as we ramp up our working hours
there's a stretch where if you're
working intently you can get a lot done
and feel great
but our brains can only handle three or
four hours of deep work per day
once you're working so much that you're
not getting enough sleep you're stressed
your personal life's under pressure
there's a steep trade-off
your critical thinking creativity and
decision making go way downhill
at that point it might be tempting to
work more for
visibility or credibility but it's not
helping your productivity
okay maybe my drawings don't convince
you but i hope that a couple of stanford
professors will
the economist john penceville did a
study on working hours
he found that after 48 hours per week
marginal productivity declines
after 60 hours it turns negative
the organizational behavior expert jeff
pfeffer did a meta analysis
on labor productivity he found
extensive evidence proving that after a
point
reducing working hours actually
increases worker health
performance and productivity
a lot of you may be familiar with
malcolm gladwell's claim that it takes
10 000 hours of practice to reach
mastery
it's based on a study of violin students
what gladwell often leaves out from that
study is what the students do
outside of practice the best students
don't just practice for 10 000 hours
they also get an hour more of sleep per
day on average
and protect their downside
i'm going to pause and take a breath
this is a chance for us to rethink our
assumptions about what hard work
and productivity need to look like the
trade-off between
feeling your best and doing your best
work is almost always a false one
our need for sleep rest and play makes
us human
and it fuels our ability to do creative
world-changing work
but whatever the science says it's hard
to resist overwork in a culture where
looking and feeling busy is such a
powerful signal of success
i also assumed that
success in high powered elite jobs
required overwork
since overwork for me means panic
attacks on a grimy airport floor
i quit my job in consulting i also
counted myself
out of banking pe vc entrepreneurship
law
politics and a lot of startups and i'm
not the only one
counting myself out anyone who wants or
needs to be an active parent
anyone with community or caregiving
responsibilities they can't ignore
anyone who knows their health can't
stand up to around the clock schedule
it's not a coincidence that in countries
with more regulations around working
hours
the gender pay gap is closing faster
than it is
in the us
so now we know us professionals work too
much
it's hurting our well-being and our work
plus normalizing overwork shuts out
certain people
from high-powered jobs
i also want to acknowledge that overwork
is a problem in all parts of the economy
not just the privileged sectors i've
been talking about
and if you depend on overtime or shift
work for survival
there's not a lot of choice in accepting
long hours
that's why it's so crucial that those of
us
who do have a choice in where and how we
work
start to change the culture
so how are we going to do this
overworked culture
can feel immutable normalized by
institutions and traditions that we
don't control
but any culture is the sum of individual
choices and actions
people particularly people with the
influence and access of many gsb
students
can start to spread a new normal
where overwork is an occasional burden
not a prerequisite for success
we can start to do this by doing three
things
first make conscious trade-offs
think for a moment now about what your
ideal week looks like
maybe there's family time volunteer work
exercise knitting whatever
now going forward pay attention to when
work cuts into those other priorities
and make sure that you feel okay about
the trade-off
don't wait 5 or 10 or 30 years of
grinding
to realize the opportunity cost of the
time you spend
working second
vote with your feet choose companies and
managers who respect your time
and who understand that you'll be even
more brilliant
when you have enough sleep rest and play
this method is actually already proven
to work more companies are willing to
consider
things like four-day weeks flexible
hours and remote work because
their talent people like you and me are
asking for it be
part of this change and ask for what you
need to feel your best
and do your best work number three
don't pay it forward when you're a
manager
don't burn out the next generation with
the same traditions and conventions that
burned you out
remember that you can generate more
creativity and better decisions on your
teams
by embracing innate constraints on
people's time and energy
i hope that we can admit at least to
ourselves
that we're not super human we can't do
everything for everyone at all hours
without a cost
when i'm beating myself up because i
can't do it all
i remember that cold gross bathroom
floor in reagan airport
and i think i'm not going to let myself
go back there
and wherever that place of shame and
exhaustion
is for you i don't want you going back
there either
overwork and burnout are not inevitable
we can start to rethink our assumptions
about hard work
and make conscious choices about the
best use of people's time and energy
thank you
you